we begin with this the Trump
administration is searching for the
right response to North Korea's first
ever intercontinental ballistic missile
test the most powerful missile the North
has ever tested marks a dramatic change
in the threat to the US from Kim Jong
Un's regime US forces in South Korea
responded overnight with a show of deep
strike missiles those missiles were
fired into South Korean waters Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson is promising
stronger measures against Kim's
government's but the u.s. has very few
workable options most feel the North
Korean leader said American jerks would
not be very happy with this gift sent on
the July 4th anniversary Ben Tracy is in
Beijing with the growing international
reaction to the missile test then good
morning
good morning well China and Russia are
now saying that they oppose any effort
to resolve the North Korean crisis by
force or with sanctions that would
strangle the country economically the
u.s. and South Korea seemed to be making
a different argument this morning with
missiles
in a large-scale military exercise
Wednesday the u.s. in South Korea
launched a barrage of missiles into the
East Sea the message to North Korea we
have weapons to and they are not far
away
in a statement that pentagon said the US
will use the full range of capabilities
at our disposal against a growing threat
from North Korea after the US military
confirmed that the regime successfully
launched an intercontinental ballistic
missile on Tuesday South Korean
officials say the missile known as the
Hasan fourteen is a two-stage weapon
with an estimated range of nearly 5,000
miles capable of hitting Alaska and even
the west coast of the United States
according to some experts inch missile
the North Korea tested before this was
back in May that had a range of maybe
about 300 miles so this is considerably
longer I think the kinds of things
they're doing will allow them to
continue to increase the range
North Korea believes that possessing
nuclear weapons capable of hitting the
u.s. is the only way to be taken
seriously the regime is developing its
weapons more rapidly than most experts
thought possible
he claims that Tuesday's tests improved
the accuracy of its ICBM and that it can
carry a large size heavy nuclear warhead
but one test does not mean that North
Korea now has a reliable
intercontinental ballistic missile
system and we don't know if they're able
to put a nuclear warhead on it as they
claim
rina Ben Tracy and Beijing Thank You Ben